[Applause]
I think
thank you very much
I I think I know why you're happy
from vacation not going well he is about
as popular right now is a norovirus on a
cruise ship Wow
Trump supporters well if there any hair
there welcome you're tired of winning
I'm asking because I feel like I feel
like the question of the week is how can
we get tired of winning if the south
won't shut up about losing I travel on
this out there a lot of gigs down there
that's not the whole south there are
many fine people in the south but not
the ones who go to Klan marches
here's a % you're not a fine person if
the guy next to you has a swastika flag
that's and
if the party you want to go to looks
like comic-con for sociopaths you are
not a fine person but look I would never
say that Donald Trump could not go lower
because he's the king of low but to
watch what went on this week in
Charlottesville and then to come out
with Nazis they're just like us
it kept kept saying this violence on
both sides okay first of all there
wasn't sorry but liberals don't form
militias they form drum circles
and even if there was which there wasn't
you know what there was violence on both
sides in world war ii we were still the
good guys I didn't agree with everything
George Bush did after 9/11 but he didn't
side with al-qaeda he didn't say some of
the hijackers were fine people I I
thought it was so fitting that the
lowest point and this lowly
administration was Tuesday the one day
he was back at Trump Tower where the
horror all began where he was fuming
that the day before he had to denounce
racists and you know as he launched into
his defense of neo-nazis who were
chanting Jews will not replace us
standing beside him was his Jewish
Treasury secretary Steve minuchin and
his Jewish economic council head Gary
Cohen now neither one of them has plans
to quit but if they do Jews will replace
them
[Applause]
so right now you know the the right wig
is all pretending that this is about
this is just about civil war monuments
you know that's what the big they
weren't racist they were just not
wanting these monuments to come down to
Robert II leave in Stonewall Jackson
Trump said this week who's next
Washington Jefferson yeah but you know
we put up statues of Washington and
Jefferson despite the fact that they
owned slaves for them slavery was a bug
for robert e lee it was a feature and
speaking of speaking of getting rid of
racist eyesores steve Bannon is out
[Applause]
yeah that was that was the big news
today Trump told him this bunker is not
big enough for the both of us no cuz
Bannon come on never got along
with Jared Kushner who will probably
take over some of his duties so again to
the people chanting Jews will not
replace this day enough the bodies are
piling up outside the White House if it
the number of people open a general
Flynn rinse Reince Priebus a Sean Spicer
the mooch Steve Madden I mean this is
gonna sound a little racist but why
can't lazy white people keep a job
[Applause]
so the question now is who is still with
Trump because even his buddies on the
right are all the manufacturing Council
has resigned the strategic Policy Forum
has resigned the Advisory Council and
infrastructure won't take his calls
anymore
Mitt Romney both bushes denounced him
conservative senators like bob Corker
denounced him and perhaps the harshest
blow of all last night Ivanka made him
sleep on the couch
[Applause]
so I know so he's a little blue so of
course what do they do with the
president's now they have a big rotli
plan they're gonna go to Phoenix big
rally in Phoenix and his handlers want
to cheer him up and they're gonna wait
to the you know the Eclipse is coming
they're gonna wait till the Eclipse
happens and then tell him there were 3
million people there and this is amazing
by sheer coincidence 92% of the eclipse
is going to be going over what they call
the path of totality where the Sun will
be completely obscured and it falls over
92% of it over counties that voted for
Trump just what we need these people
even more in the dark